they want to be able to dictate the
public narrative and they and you know
when somebody when there's threats out
there that are drawing all the eyeballs
away from them they get scared and
because they're weak and pathetic they
go straight for century censorship let's
well let's let's carry on we we do have
a lot to talk about with the with the
great honking and what's going to be
happening in the us but let's let's
carry this conversation forward talking
about what's going on with joe rogan we
have this story from timcast.com rumble
publicly offers joe rogan 100 million
dollars for a four-year censorship free
contract rumble posted hey joe rogan we
are ready to fight alongside you saying
how about you bring all of your shows to
rumble both old and new with no
censorship for 100 million bucks over
four years this is our chance to save
the world and yes this is totally legit
based on the reporting about rumble's uh
special purpose acquisition company 2.1
billion evaluation and potentially 400
million dollars in liquid cash to spend
i think they could do this
but i don't see why joe rogan would do
this because it would be basically him
saying that he wants to say the n-word
that's that's that's the issue right now
so it's like not a good time to offer
joe rogan 100 million dollars for
censorship free contract because the
issue at hand is that joe himself
according to the spotify ceo is the one
who took down all of the episodes last
friday
but that apology video man that joe put
out was a mistake it's making everything
worse and perhaps the issue is
when people say joe has few money
maybe it means few to everybody and a
lot of people who are libertarian
freedom loving uh you know who want
honesty integrity assume joe is on their
side when in reality joe is just joe and
just
is an honest guy you know what i mean
yeah he's doing his own thing and
doesn't necessarily have a particular
ideology sort of what you're saying like
he's like obviously
i am
offended
by the lies of the mainstream press yeah
and i'll call them out and i stand for
that joe is offended they lied about him
and lie often
but
isn't interested in getting involved in
a fight to change the future of media
you know what i mean yeah i'm not saying
it's true yeah he's not a hero like
don't don't put this guy in a pedestal
he's just a dude live doing his life man
which also goes to show like how just
ridiculous the attacks against tamar
because his like what is his show their
unfiltered conversations for about three
hours at a time with people of all
different opinions political persuasions
it's not even all political and so the
fact that you know big institutional
powers find this guy a threat who just
has unfiltered conversations with people
yeah well one thing lefties do and i'm
not exactly sure how if this has been
the case with the joe rogan experience
but i would be very surprised if it
wasn't because it's something you've
dealt with it's something that virtually
every large political show that i'm
aware of or has spoken about this
has dealt with but left-wing people will
refuse to do a podcast if it's hosted
too many right-wing people and so then
you only have people who are moderate or
on the right doing the podcast no
lefties do it and then lefties go oh my
gosh why aren't we being represented why
can't our views get out there it's not
it's it's you're you're you're close
it's not that it's too many right-wing
people it's too many it's that the host
has an opinion contrary to this yes all
right fair enough and so they'll go i'm
not going to go on this podcast and so
i'm i am sure and again i can't say for
certain i don't know i don't speak for
joe organ but i'm sure that there's a
lot of left-wing people who absolutely
could do the joe rogan experience and
let the audience know what their
opinions are but they see joe rogan as a
non-person he's an evil bigot so why
even engage with him or his audience
kyle kolinsky said that in his episode
joe never used a slur
but
he was very critical of saudi arabia and
spotify has just opened up their market
to saudi arabia some people said that
joe mentioned a song lyric with a slur
in it i don't know you know uh kyle
kalinski said there was no slur in it we
also have these tweets from adam kokesh
where he said joe basically told him
spotify is not allowing him on the show
and that they took down a show because
he had too much misinformation in it
that sounds to me like
that does not sound true to be
completely honest like i don't see joe
rogan as the kind of guy to like call
somebody up and be like dude i'm so
sorry to take your episode down it's
because it was misinformation like those
are words that joe doesn't or probably
won't use
so maybe the real issue is that joe
did talk to adam kokesh and said
something like
look man spotify doesn't want you know
these kind of shows and there were
issues with like the facts that the
things that were being said they weren't
true so that you know they didn't want
it on their platform and then adam
frames it as such like misinformation
uses those words right exactly but as i
say if that if that statement from adam
is true
then this is crazy this is seriously
crazy joe outright being like spotify is
pulling the strings yeah i mean it's a
very much he said he said situation we
don't well joe didn't say anything yeah
well exactly so we have one person
leveling an accusation and we have to
assume innocence until there's proof of
guilt we have to remain agnostic on this
but i would also say that well yeah that
doesn't sound like something joe rogan
would do to me i don't know him
as a person and he's also not the kind
of person i would have figured as a
public apology kind of guy either so who
knows i think he views this show his
show as like a little side project and
he wants it in a box just like wrapped
up and not stressing his life out i saw
him on instagram he's like this is how
i'm dealing with all the bs and it's
like they light a gorilla piece of
gorilla ice cream on fire and they're
like and i'm on mushrooms was part of it
i was like yeah dude he just wants to
live man
if it gets too much of a hassle then
it's too much of a hazard you move on to
something else so i think what we see
from all of this is that
people shouldn't assume joe rogan is a
warrior like you said like fighting on
your side in the culture war he's a guy
who has conversations you happen to
agree with him on a decent amount of
those opinions that's about it yeah he's
not going to save you or back you up
unless he really believes it sorry
sheamus yeah well or
literally people he's platformed he did
literally save us with uh with uh you
know he's so legit he's just such a kind
person if you watch his fear factor
stuff in the early days he's got this
like um this like uh innate ability to
motivate and and give courage
it's just such a kind like a gentle
guerrilla yeah
okay well was the circling back though
to i just want to reaffirm that yeah i
mean anything
anything anyone has said that he is said
or done behind closed doors like that we
don't have any confirmation on with
respect to that we catch situation you
have to like sort of stay on the side of
we don't know and we can't jump to
conclusions about it i want to say you
know i want to make sure this is in you
every time i bring up a video about joe
that he's helped me out tremendously
having me on his show helped my career
tremendously uh having me on with ceo of
jack or ceo of twitter jack dorsey was
just insane for me at the time so i'm
like dude i'm just some dude on youtube
with like 100 000 subs like why am i
sitting in front of the ceo of this
major biggest you know one of the
biggest companies in the world and so
you know joe had me on and he said that
you know i thought he thought i was a
smart guy and i held my own he
appreciated it he opted out with our
medical issues so i think he's genuinely
just like a really good dude and i think
i don't think he ever expected to be in
this position i think he even said that
he just wanted to hang out and talk with
his friends and all of a sudden he had
this big show and it's crazy and he just
wants to chill
but i will say
i think this is the the the
it's it's it's the it's it's all
downhill from here well the rumble thing
i like i like that chris did this chris
pavlosi because this is a big it's a
it's a big statement it's it's
legitimate he will pay joe 100 million
if he does it but it also tells spotify
if you
mess with joe too much
there's a exit ramp for this dude so
don't mess with this guy because the
world loves him i think i think it's all
downhill from here in terms of what
happened to the joe rogan experience as
as joe stated right when he made this
this video compilation of him saying the
n words really old it was resurfaced by
a super pac group or something like that
his his position is my understanding
first of all he's never used the slur he
said this a big difference
citing the name of certain you know
comedy specials referencing the word
itself
but he recently came out and said
there are a lot of people that think
there's no context in which a white
person can say this word and i agree
with that now and i haven't said it for
years
that's the change in joe where he's like
okay i'll take this stuff down
but that is a very very important change
to reference
i think i'll say it this way
there is no context in which you will
not face severe repercussions
for saying the word descriptively the
n-word right and it becomes very
difficult then when you want to
reference the names of documentaries
because there's there's um different
forms of what we would call the n-word
and this is already a very difficult
conversation to have because it's hard
for me to actually tell you what the
words are because if we say it youtube
will take the show down outright this is
why i think we're at a very we're having
a very serious problem
in our public discourse
there is no reason why a smart honest
individual can't describe a word in fact
there are words that sound like the
n-word you can't say either a guy got
canceled like fox news and he used the
word i can't say that meant shrewd and
they attacked him for it
it is absolutely insane
that you have an executive at netflix
was telling people here's a list of
offensive words that should not be aired
on on our programs and he got fired for
telling people the word not to say
this is psychotic
when joe says
you know after a few years i realized
yes you're right we should not be able
to describe this word
i completely disagree but it shows you
the cultural defeat because that
literally makes no sense none whatsoever
while i will absolutely acknowledge
we absolutely we we of course will never
reference there's i think six five or
six words we're talking about in a
members only podcast that start with
letter n but are not the same word that
you can't say for a variety of reasons
one of them i'm willing to actually say
it's nazi
by saying that youtube has already
probably struck the channel we're
probably down ranked d monetized all of
that stuff because youtube doesn't think
that
content is appropriate for advertisers
so you get hurt by it
there's other words that are referenced
in documentaries that are not the
typical n-word but still are considered
offensive by today's standards i can't
describe that word to you or explain to
you what it is it makes it impossible to
explain to people what's going on at all
for joe to come out and be like i agree
i agree there's no context i'm like
that's hardcore bending the knee to an
extreme degree here's what i would say
there are certain contexts where you
need to describe what words people
shouldn't be using in derogatory context
we're not allowed to say those words
because the machine by which we have
this show on will ban us
outright imagine if but
on in the members only segment we've had
this conversation before and we still
refrain from using certain words but we
still get smeared for it anyway trying
to explain to people we simply want them
to understand context you're not allowed
i think that's a fair way to put it
joe actually just cited with the left's
perspective that you shouldn't be
allowed to describe words
yeah i was thinking like what if your
kid comes to you is like daddy why why
is this word so bad and aston says the
word and you're like
i can't talk about it like could you
imagine not being able to communicate
with your child and explain why things
are the way they are i'm not living that
life well one thing i found really funny
about this story is after they canceled
joe rogan or tried to cancel him over
this
uh video resurfaced to use that lovely
euphemism by the way that means they dug
it up somebody went looking for it and
found it but uh footage also resurfaced
of joe biden saying the n-word and we're
being told that we have to look at that
contextually but not when joe rogan used
it well here's the thing none of them
actually care like yeah i'm pretty sure
most rational people don't live under
this perspective that anyone who's ever
said that word no matter the context
should be cancelled to platformed et
cetera they want to they want to the
platform joe rogan and they're going to
do anything to do it they have they're
going to dig up anything they're going
they'll go into through any great length
to cancel his show because it's a threat
to the institutional power of the
establishment
many people pointed out sexism is next
they're gonna pull up the things he said
about women then you're gonna have
homophobia then you're gonna have
transphobia these videos all exist
already the the the video of joe and the
planet of the ape story has been around
for years it's a very very old video
joe
apologizing in my opinion is him
basically giving up
like like he doesn't it's what i'm
saying he doesn't want to fight i'm not
saying he has to fight i'm not saying i
just it's i'm mad at him for not wanting
to fight i'm saying like he said man
he's just wanted to hang out with his
friends and talk about stuff and now
he's in this position
i shouldn't maybe giving up is
inappropriate because it implies he
wanted this fight in the first place i
think joe's stood up for himself on many
occasions like when he challenged sanjay
gupta on cnn this is clearly a fight
he's not willing to stand up for himself
on i think he's deflected it he's a jiu
jitsu master that's one way to call it
black
he's also a black belt in jiu jitsu
yeah from eddie bravo i saw a video of
it it's on youtube um of him giving him
the belt it's real emotional but he's
also a mental jujitsu artist he knows
how to maneuver energy so that it
doesn't get in his way
i appreciate that about joe but do you
do you feel that's really what he's done
in this situation it's kind of like in
him it's what he is kind of he's very
very very not passive but able to pass
through things i'm i literally don't
understand his his thinking on this one
at all yeah these people who don't watch
his show they they don't like him
they're never going to like him
apologizing will do nothing and by
apologizing what's happening now is all
of these videos are popping up with
people being like whoa joe rogan
admitted it he admitted to everything he
said he's admitted he's gotten a great
detail about it and he said he thought
it was entertaining like dude
the people who like you don't know don't
care they've seen your show already
they've watched your show from the
beginning they get it the people who
don't like you
they're never gonna like you guys so
what is the point i want to point this
out there is something inherently absurd
with the idea of apologizing to a group
of people who are literally saying that
context doesn't matter because that
means the context of your apology
doesn't matter all they see is you
bending the knee and then they want more
this is some oh are you going to say
something
well working at mines i i co you know
worked with mine for a long time
co-founded the company with bill bill
often the ceo and he kept telling me it
was like 2013 14 15 16 he was like
context matters and i i was like yeah i
know bill but like and he's like conte
like talking about how to administrate
the website context matters a robot
cannot take a tech piece of text out of
it makes no sense it can but it makes no
sense ethically or constructively you
know morally to do that so context but
how do you teach a a computer system
about context well here's the here's the
thing like social media is is not
context doesn't exist on twitter or on
the internet or anything like this like
the goal of people on these platforms is
just to beat you until you submit to
them and so like if so if you're you
know if you're anybody who gets caught
in one of these situations like you
can't bend the knee like because they
won't care they're they're never going
to stop like you know glenn younkin the
governor of virginia did something like
this over the weekend where he
apologized for a tweet where he his
campaign account made fun of this high
school kid who tweeted a viral lie about
him but like obviously they didn't
obviously they didn't they were like oh
this isn't a real apology like you can't
bend the knee to these people at all
because they all they want is your
career to be destroyed yes and so you
have to stand up to them and even if it
is an authentic apology even if they
accept that it's an authentic apology
this is not a group of people that
believes in forgiveness or redemption
you are always the person who did that
and they will always smear you with it
and i do believe this is a great
conversation the we talked about this
before the show using a slur at someone
and talking about a word are different
different environments different
meanings and so that sort of seems to
have been lost any word in the flow of
text yeah yeah uh so i i truly believe
that talking about words that have been
used as racist slurs in the past is very
important for our species to evolve and
move past it and and make it part of us
and then like old words that used to be
really offensive we don't they're not
offensive anymore a lot of those words
yeah that's just the nature of human
communication yeah no exactly i mean so
so if um you know a child uses a swear
word they drop the f-bomb and then dad
gets home from work and mom goes johnny
said what the f and she drops the the
word there is a world of difference
between that and her husband coming home
from work and she looks at him and she
says fu like she's saying the f word in
both contexts or in both situations but
the context is extremely different in
one situation she is actually using it
to hurt someone and in the other
situation she's using it to either
illustrate a point or to describe what
someone else has said
so necessary and i want to bring that
back to social media somehow to culture
to common culture
joe like is like the hot tip of the
spear here man but i'm i you know this
is a conversation that's necessary
but like when you're on the internet
though it's like oh you said this word
you shouldn't have a thing anymore like
these things don't exist on twitter it's
not it's not a place where nuances this
is the the news outlets are all saying
video of joe using exactly the n-word
and so even if you even if you want to
argue that there's a better euphemism to
use for the word when describing it it's
clear that there is a
very large difference between using it
and referencing yeah if you had like a
bunch of blocks of letters that said the
word and you took a sledgehammer and
smashed them you'd be using the word
but in like an alliterative artistic
manner we know the media falsely frames
things we know that all they do they'll
they'll twist whatever you did in any
way possible to push the narrative they
want i'll tell you what i think
i think joe's deal with spotify people i
see people chatting and they're like
they're in the chat saying you know he's
probably got an nda he's probably got
morality clauses about what he can and
can't do about controversies and
spotify probably told him to apologize
or whatever and he can't talk about it
i don't know i think uh i think joe's
probably got equity in i think he got
shares of spotify
when you think about the biggest podcast
in the world
what's the real incentive for going
exclusive
there have been many outlets many many
tech companies who have asked me and
they're like you know how about an
equity deal and i'm just like not
interested i literally don't care about
that but i understand why someone would
say it's a good deal i mean think about
it the wall street journal reports that
joe rogan gets a hundred million dollars
they say it's a multi-year contract
everyone assumes this always means cash
it doesn't so my contract with fusion
which was the abc news univision joint
venture was valued at like three to five
million dollars but direct compensation
was only like 700. the rest of the stuff
was like discretionary budget staffing
hiring but it was a big contract so if
you're trying to do a big pitch you can
be like spotif you know you could be
like you know disney nabs up tim pool
with a five million dollar contract or
something like that it sounds like i'm
getting all this money i'm not getting
in my opinion
i don't know exactly what the you know
the specifics of joe's deal uh with
spotify was but i'd imagine they
probably came to him and said x amount
of cash x amount of shares and maybe
like a bonus or something like that
i would imagine in a boat for jamie like
so so actually so so uh ian you're
having worked with mines like you've
worked a lot of companies they offer
equity as incentives to sign on people
and stuff yeah a lot of times what you
do is you vest the equity meaning that
you sign a contract saying i'm gonna
work here for this amount of time five
years and every year i'll earn a portion
of my percentage of equity that i would
be earning in total so for me it was one
percent of the mine stock uh every year
i would get like 0.3 or 0.2 and as long
as i stayed at the company i would keep
accruing it and if i left at any time
i'd have what i had so let's say that
100 million deal for rogan was outright
because you know he still has he sells
commercials on the show right
yes on spotify he does like vod is that
what it's called
he says them directly direct direct ad
sales so i'd imagine spotify would have
nothing to do that's a licensing deal
right
so let's say the spotify went to him and
said
it's a multi-year contract and we'll
give you 100 million dollars in
in equity right now
right now as soon as he signs that deal
the stock jumped by what like 20 percent
yeah
so i don't know exactly what the
specifics of their deal was
but i would imagine a good reason why
joe probably came out and apologized
he's got equity in the company
interesting
yeah it has nothing to do with canceled
culture has nothing to do it's just
literally like how can i you know make
sure this isn't going bad for everybody
who's you know investing in this company
i think it's multi-layered obviously
obviously i think joe obviously doesn't
like the fact that that video exists i
think he's very i think he's genuine and
sincere when he was like man i watched
that video and i'm like i cringe
watching it you know i you know wish i
could say these things and some of these
things were crude and crass i think he's
genuine but i think you know part of the
motivation is
you know god's got to protect his
business got to protect his assets and i
don't i think everyone just assumes
i've seen a lot of people on the left
pointing this out people on the right
just assume joe rogan is on their side
in this great culture war battle and
he just happens to agree with him a lot
of things but joe rogan is just a
comedian and entertainer who talks about
stuff he cares about don't expect him to
jump in the line of fire for you
but at the same time like defending free
speech defending you know
unfilled the unfiltered conversations
that he has i think it's important for
our discourse and i think it's even more
important is that he he gives another
side of the story that very very
powerful institutions want to censor and
so the reason you know i i think the
reason like most people admire joe rogan
and defend joe rogan people on the right
i would say is for those reasons because
like you know people we believe in free
speech we believe that it's important to
talk about things and not and that's and
that censorship is for weak people and
so like in terms when you just thinking
in terms of defending this idea of free
speech without censorship i think that's
why the people on the right defend them
in the way that they've been doing
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast if you
want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at 8
pm and don't forget to smash that like
button subscribe to this channel and if
you want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time
you